uh
ep of the podcast buttholes
oh hey guys how does neil feel welcome
to the show
well i've just set some things in my
watch if you guys don't mind
yeah hi everyone sorry no
uh bianca is doing her last looks
if you get this text it's too late i've
already recorded a podcast
uh bianca hey
how was your week okay i have
okay i did i i i booked
a commercial for this diamond facial
fantastic so what do you have to do is
it uh
print it was just it was digital this
one was digital and it was
just they gave it visual means the
internet but that's like a there's
it sounds shitty but it's a big it's a
bigger it's a
you can't even imagine it's a while more
digital but there's bigger digital buys
now than tv buys
exactly so um and then they gave me a
facial
with diamonds so it's like a
tip it's like a diamond did you open
your mouth and
try to catch some diamonds so you could
you could change them as they say not
how you catch them you say in prison
and then you put them in your cheeks no
and they take a diamond thing and they
remove like a whole layer from your face
of i thought of you of sort of a sort of
stuff just gunk just a dead skin
interesting and it was fantastic and
then i threw my friend a baby shower
well well well did your ovaries hurt no
um i threw around a baby shower also
have you been to a baby shower you look
like you're on your way to one
uh i'm loving your comedy i always have
um
i'm wearing pink he's wearing a light
because i don't i'm uh sorry low hanging
fruit i don't
i'm uh just a visitor to the earth and
your colors mean
nothing to me uh i've been to i don't
think i have i've been to a
christian that that thing or the video
chris
you've been here i've been nervous yeah
i didn't like it wait did they
snip there yeah
no he didn't suck it though that's
that's the weird thing we don't talk
yeah we don't do that that's not good we
don't do that um
i just you at parties is it's one of my
favorite
images images yeah something that
somehow you swear
certain parties i would not mind a it
was an
ex made me go to someone she worked with
it's just one of these things like
you don't want to go why are you making
me like
why put me through this so i just the
whole time my energy was why are you
putting me through this
like an hour and a half two hours of
just nonsense
just fake relationships with people she
didn't she like stopped working there
two months late it just like this is a
total
sham right from top to bottom
now now are you just like i i don't want
to go to that
or would you be there uh i
i don't know what i mean now i don't i
think i would say i
i think it's it's not for me i would
feel i don't have the life
i don't have the life force i don't want
to spend my life force
on that that's good my limited time here
on
the planet well um making a baby shower
with a group of women
i was basically on a committee it was
my nightmare i couldn't believe how
dramatic it was
yeah i was like eat cake open presents
call it a day no
no no it's a weekend we need i want to
i didn't you didn't text me back about
the plates how are we doing this
what are we doing what colors who's
doing that somebody make a playlist
i was losing my mind yeah but it turned
out great so
um not yeah not worth it
no not i mean from having a baby
to the shower not working also neil
you're not going to go to any
celebration of climate climate deniers
yeah climate deniers festival uh
with a with like a with a with like a
obelisk at the center that they lift up
like a giant like here it is
the yes the the environmental record
um what'd you do what did i do
that i did a show saturday night in
escandido escondido california
and somebody had a seizure in the middle
of the show which is never
funny you are funny the guy had a
seizure
and but it wasn't it was like
get help and his wife or girlfriend
immediately started crying like
immediately
he'd never had a seizure before
someone i knew was there who was a nurse
who was a
nurse practitioner which is well way
better than a nurse apparently they
always they like to remind you
um and she so i knew it was gonna be
cool and then there was another guy who
took care of it and the guy
came to within two to three minutes
and so i said like sir what joke made
you have a senior
i will punish it and we i just
continued or did he leave he got up
because they had to call the 9-1-1 and
then the ambulance came and
like it was they never returned no
they had to they had if they call 9-1-1
and you you have to
kind of follow through ex do
something with like you have to like
ride the on the side of the ambulance
you have to do is you have to take a
picture with the ambulance something
that prevents you from watching comedy
right um but it was on like minute 50
so it wasn't a tragedy how much
uh did it like disturb the vibe
not that much callous crews because he
got up he walked away
so it wasn't it wasn't deaf it was like
it was death
for 90 seconds and then it became
life became very regular life
with a newfound appreciation for not
dying yeah
so we all had a new lease on life and
for the
last nine minutes were pretty special
gosh i wonder what
ha why i he'd never had one before so i
don't know
um [ __ ]
he seemed okay he walked i mean like i
think he drove home i don't
you can't drive when you have caesars
well i guess i'll give you his name and
you can call the governor
okay um i will uh
so that was saturday yeah and then
yesterday
i experienced uh plant medicine okay
and but that's who who didn't hear any
more of that
no on a podcast well you didn't add to
your bracelet connection i didn't
had to embrace it i did have a did
receive a guilla
which is a necklace not wearing it
because you can only wear it
during plant ceremonies thank you now
uh did you see the grammys actively
was not interested didn't i didn't watch
a frame of it i didn't either
i did get a text of like how good are
the grammys i'm like
i just i find award shows right now
strange i find i okay i was gonna ask
because oscar nominations came out today
yes i saw and our
friend of the podcast dana kaluuya
godzilla
a uh best supporting that's a is he not
the main
him and lakeith both received best
supporting which is
it's the first movie without a lead okay
yeah which is
it should get an award for that that
they made a whole movie without a lead
person
i've seen people get lead for less way
less
um they're like we can't give them lead
well no i i don't
i think they i've they both put
themselves up for that
it's like oh so you nominate yourself
well yeah or somebody nominated right
right um
so i trayvon
from my group chat trayvon free
the guy talking about on the show he got
nominated for best show
and i i don't i'm like cool i
i don't know it seems just odd and i
don't know if it's my own wait what
seems odd
like you said it's weird to have award
shows now
um also i feel so
removed from the world i don't maybe
it's
it's it's combination starch children
and i just i i've thought
reward shows were silly for a decade
probably and they just now it's getting
the point where i don't even understand
them like
what you're getting in a w so i'm happy
for those guys
and but i don't i don't know they can't
pause them obviously
the award shows but it just seems like
couldn't they just
give them without a ceremony
just instead of announcing nominees it's
like these people won
yeah but i think that uh the they're so
used to the promotional
yeah nature of it grist that it's it's
grist for the promotional military i had
a
were you ever i might have jumped this
were you in a video with trayvon
like a like a slow-mo behind the scenes
with music i don't think so i think i
jumped in you dreamt it yeah
congratulations
was lauren there now
so grandmas didn't see uh beyonce want
to buy it's just i don't
just like oh beyonce one and taylor
swift one and they but the fact that
anyone's interested it's like what
i think you should be interested if
you're in that industry
or or you're elected or you're up for
something cool yeah if you're up for it
okay most people aren't i i don't know i
just
we gotta keep podcasting guys there's
some type of noises are gonna happen we
have to keep
fight fighters scared me for a second um
yeah i don't know something about it
feels
uh uh it's just like give it a second
yeah because also how do
like what do we know what was popular
you know people work but it's not a
matter of popular it's quality
it's a quality thing from within coming
from in the house
yeah for sure but for example like
there was let's say let's say with the
oscars there's no movie theaters there's
no
those kind of numbers saying like wow
this is but they don't that doesn't
really affect it i know it doesn't
affect it but it would be i feel like
that makes people more engaged
in the like well there's i yeah i wonder
how many more downloads
i mean i guess it's just trying to get
money they're just trying to make money
trying to promote their [ __ ] and make
and like turn it into a competition like
american idol but you don't nobody
but they their audition is streaming
um you're not gonna believe this
what catholic church not gonna anoint
gay marriage
can you [ __ ] believe it neil these
are your people i
i'm shy i would call the vatican i call
this the hot one oh the vatican
i call the hotline endlessly and uh
they won't bless them wait they
that's a direct quote from the from
that's from
they the cannot god cannot bless sin
so whoops there you go
gays you thought you weren't sinning
surprise you're still sinning bad news
you can't get married
good news sex just got hotter
i just who's after this who is after the
anointment of who needs a blessing
well in some ways it's not unlike
the weekend getting mad that he didn't
get nominated for a grammy it's like
what do you need why do you need their
approval
the catholic uh
[Music]
anointment it gets you nothing
you get a grammy's more valuable right
you can you get a trophy
yeah you could sell it you could sell it
you could sell the trophy you might
you it's good for grammys are especially
good for intros
like grammy yeah yeah they're great um
gay marriage gets you nothing so
wait no no blessing anointing gay
marriage
no the mayor i'm no i didn't miss
speaker i'm saying wait a minute
get married no i'm saying the blessing
what the [ __ ] is up
what are they talking about like sorry
our fake organization can't bless
you filled with sin i mean
gay marriage you know how many priests
are bummed right now that they're not
gonna be able to
they're like getting married to their
boy they're molesting when
when he comes of age um they're free
they just they
but it's good for gay priests because
they're like sorry i'd love to but i
can't
it reminds me of when i was in china i
was understanding the pettiness
of the chinese government and apparently
this
llama died not that animal like not the
dalai lama but another
llama and it's funny if you picture it
as a llama though
the lava died so alama died
and in their religion they believed that
in reincarnation and the chinese
government said they were
undecided on whether they were going to
let him reincarnate
like we we don't we haven't approved the
reincarnation yet
we'll put we'll run up the flag but
no promises it's just like okay um
so sorry guys um sorry guys
sorry gays yeah you don't get to visit
the host there's not you get
nothing you if if you in order to visit
your lover in the hospital or your
husband or wife
at the hospital you have to be legally
married it has got nothing to do with
the church
so you're getting if this you have to be
a little delusional for that to matter
like you i mean it's not like a badge
like i'm
blessed out of my way you know so it has
to like what
well you're catholic so what does it
mean
there are people that are
like that guy andrew sullivan the who's
like kind of a
conservative journalist yeah a bad guy
gay but kind of has to
he like i believe he's still catholic
and likes the church
okay so it's for him they might as well
said sorry andrew that might have
been the headline like that i don't
i just think he he he wants it
it means a lot to him but i don't know
if he knows why it means a lot to him
right
it might just be a childhood thing like
it's like people defending the crown
which we'll get to um
you grew up in the catholic church so
i'm wondering
are there people not necessarily gay
people that
being annoying to being blessed is
extremely important or is everyone kind
of like
yeah we're here so openly gay
no just in general just being blessed
like having the blessings like
did or is it just like we're all doing
this because we kind of think
i don't think anyone
look i'm a [ __ ] star child and the
sooner people realize it the better
i don't think people people's
understanding of religion
is true of course i just don't i think
that
they want to believe they want to fit in
they want to
so i think that it's a club that you can
get
status in through a variety of ways
right
so they want higher one of them is being
annoyed yeah you get it
it's vip you're not allowed to get the
the eucharist
no wine for you you can but you didn't
because you
the technicality we caught you in okay
you're living with your hus so
right it's just there are people that
are their membership
is being hindered by
what where they like genitals and where
they like to put there
all right so that then you would say
well why don't you not be in the club
because they want to because it's
because they believe that that's the
only way they're going to get
uh to become infinite and divine like
um
right yeah that old guy
that old thing are you starting to
see the the light at the end of the
tunnel
is stressing me out why
because i have a lot of [ __ ] to do
when it opens oh you're like i'm
i i didn't make much of a secret about
enjoying this
and now that it's gonna end i'm like
okay i guess we'll we'll i mean there's
not i'm
i'm i am genuinely happy to do the work
i have to do but
calendars and you know conference calls
and [ __ ] that
there's going to be pressure on me in
six months it's not on me now
it's like when you are looking for a job
and you really want a job
and then you get a job starting monday
starting monday
and it's like [ __ ] i can't just chill
how great desperation is chilling with
an underlying desperation
is chilling i wish if only if i knew how
good that desperation was
we'll click on that poll uh it's just
people are kind of stressed out
yeah that's what i like they're starting
and also fewer people
people intend to not go out when it
opens up liars
so people are saying that they are gonna
go out less
people are saying like i enjoyed a
smaller social circle
at my house there's something i just
because think about it it's going to get
warmer
the risk is going to go down now
we should keep in mind you just went
through the horror of planning a
baby shower that would have been
terrible
no matter what was going on in the world
yeah there were some egos
those aren't they didn't just come out
that's what i think people are
realizing what about pre-covet is that
they had people in their life that were
not
helpful or enjoyable and that they were
doing things they did not want to do
i feel like it's going to turn into do
you remember going to asia
and out in asia and going out there was
going with your friends to eat in a
group
and not leaving the table like
in asia in china
it's kind of but i never i went by
myself so it wasn't loser
no i just i so when you go out there
interesting person what full personality
satisfies me so um
yeah no so the culture's more like me
you will and a few of us go out we just
drink together at our table eat drink
blah blah blah
and then there's not as much mingling
with strangers i feel like that's kind
of going to be the
going out a commute you're talking about
kind of community communal table
no of your communal of your community
okay so not
before you know people smash into big
got it
you know smashing into little bars
chatting mingling bumping into people
hey what it like
yeah we're very friendly that that's you
by the way i'm like i wasn't like
okay but you've been you've lived in new
york and new york everything is so
goddamn small so
yeah the bars are little it's not weird
literally you start with you don't know
me
and then you fight them proving my point
okay
that people are not interacting with
people they don't know because that's
the main reason
that people fight it's because they
don't know each other and they don't
give the other person an opportunity
to know them they'd rather fight them
than open themselves up
this is fun okay
coming to you live uh i can't read this
but
i assume it's good it's so small yeah
it's fine
well so you think you okay think of your
social friends
because you're you know yeah do you
think they'll they're a little
they're a little different
let me think about this i don't know i
don't know
i mean most of my friends were always
working at the comedian so
working at night dinner
i think i i'd hoped that people would
introverts would get would be able to be
more introverted
or at least acknowledge that they were
introverted i don't know why i wanted
that other than like because that's what
i'm like
i don't actually really care if people
go out if you like going out go out but
i guess i'm
if there were people that were locked
into habits they're now allowed to break
them
yeah um so
bet break them okay
enjoy breaking your habits and i and
people now
it's what i said early in the
in the in the pandemic it's half time so
now you can decide
what do you want to do
[Music]
in the second half the funny thing is i
wonder how many people are gonna feel
like
they were [ __ ] babies
you know when everyone makes us think
but once you get your way
you just what babies about what about
crovid and corona
what uh go on meaning like a lot of
people made a huge stink about it and a
huge this and it's like
it's a sham is it this and it just has
naturally taken a course
and all the models have been roughly
correct and everything that fouching all
these people have said has
turned out like hey if we do this the
numbers will go down
we'll help healthcare workers blah blah
so now that it's just
is doing what it said i feel like
there's a lot of people who
made such a big deal about it
that now yes but they'll say
they i don't you know i think you're
asking people to admit
uh that they made a mistake which is or
that maybe they overreacted
uh but they didn't the other the
opposite was never proof that the
opposite was never pursued
what what they wanted we just like let's
[ __ ] open up baby and we
no masks there some of the biker rallies
yeah which i still i've started to look
at that and they're like
you know five billion cases starting
starting you're like that seems
impossible but no they traced back i
think
200 000. 200 000 like at first it was
like 30 and then
and that just it's like a ripple effect
yeah yeah i don't
think people will i don't think those
people regret it i think those people
will say i don't know that's
fake you can just say they weren't fake
faked and all the people that acted like
they didn't want the vaccine are going
to
be like i always wanted that no i didn't
have a problem with the vaccine no i'm
not saying you no i'm just
joking yes um you
no having said that you did say you were
going to give it a second no i said i
was
concerned that's big
i know what you mean i don't know i
totally actually
need to take a standbys i don't think
it's a big deal to
be concerned about getting a vaccine i
think that's a big deal at all
i think it's a big deal when you're
saying weird anti-vac [ __ ]
right but it's fine to be concerned
about i i take i'm concerned about any
medicine i take
you know what i mean and i look up the
side effects and i have had really bad
side effects from a lot of different
medicines so
i'm also give me an example just because
i um one i
don't want to say but
this medicine made my breasts grow
a cup size which guys at this size
that's a danger you had to get a bigger
apartment
like disproportionately nothing else
great that's probably the pill no
no i don't want to say what it was
second of all if i guess
you'll probably spill it no still water
then
damn titties them in gorge cities
everyone at work was calling me sugar
problems they're like put your sugar
plums away
they were nothing in england in the
1700s go ahead
nothing grew on me except my boobs they
were hot and heavy
and it was really scary and my doctor
was like we need to monitor this because
i'm not sure why you're
like monitored let's just stop one thing
changed
uphill right but i needed you needed
guy so it's just weird i don't know so
anyways i'm just really careful
about like anything why not i didn't go
and like
spout like misinformation yeah so what
no i don't know because it seemed like i
remembered don't make me feel bad
okay i remember i didn't want to be
inconsistent
in terms of people going like nobody
said like bianca
but i didn't want to be inconsistent in
terms of you being concerned about it
well then i honestly i just started
researching because yeah i
literally just did research and i uh
because you know they were saying it's a
different method of
vaccine then you go and realize like
that's been around for actually the
person that developed has been around
for
12 years yeah i know you just get
information and you feel comfortable and
also
even people are like i like the old
i don't like this i don't know like why
don't
if you listen if you read that
interminably long
lawrence wright article in the new
yorker
all the info it's all in the story of it
the guy
who just kind of discovered rna
technology it he's a guy in a lab he's
not an evil guy
it's also didn't just happen yeah
exactly
he discovered it a decade ago and then
he was like
this might work for that right
particular thing it wasn't
like what like it was he didn't run into
the
and he didn't do it last night he didn't
do it in june
like i've discovered yeah also though i
mean
the astrazeneca ones are causing blood
clots and they're being stopped
like people aren't used distributing
them in like germany israel
so there is you know yeah yeah there's
never you can't clot this blood yeah
um yeah so i'm a little more stressed
than
and i'm not actually stressed but i
enjoyed
the time out time out and
i loved the fact that nobody had to
achieve anything
that it was you didn't have to achieve
anything and the people that did
the winners last night you're like what
okay
are you [ __ ] weirdo do you think this
is just gonna be everyone's like lost
year
like this is just the last years i don't
know i mean in terms of
com there wasn't nothing happened
it feels like nothing happened it when i
when i say last year i really mean 2019.
i'm like oh i went to yeah yeah outside
yeah
it's outside yours honestly it's like
yeah it's like back when this was
yeah we would go outside and we all had
to achieve
right it kind of was good and bad
it was it had plus and minuses plus was
uh you could go outside and breathe
the minus was you had to be cool and
achieve [ __ ] and
and position yourself culturally okay
so human beings are really brittle and
fragile
and you know old ladies that
were children during the great
depression that they still can
everything and won't give anything away
even in their 90s do you think
this is gonna have some sort of
psychological fashion on people or is
everyone like
i'd say a poll about uh
child bearing that
they did that they it's
it's two things that i found interesting
there were
obviously fewer babies in 2020 like
significantly
but the bigger thing was it made people
cautious about having babies
because it was like because it's like
not
like i have to actually raise these
[ __ ]
it was more the world is
fragile and and people were more
in this one study voiced more
environmental concern
because they're like oh so wet markets
with bats
are not i don't think people knew that
was happening of course they didn't but
there there are degrees of it well no i
to your point
there are meat packing plants like
they're you know what i mean they're
they're people are just more aware of
like
yeah it's not good oh wait a minute
things can jump species which is which
is part of why they wanted to be bill
gates
do you know like a part of part of the
reason is if it's bill gates then we
don't have to change anything right we
just have
something else that has killed bill
gates kill bill
gates of hell the amount of gates of
hell memes
they're funny kind of yeah i mean in a
weird way if yes
if you you're afraid of uh nerds with
[ __ ] amazing brains that's my
greatest fear
is nerds with amazing brains who gonna
microtribute
you're carrying his phone i just want to
rest restate what i said a year ago
he could get anything any information on
you that he wanted
he could you're as good as microchipped
as we speak
but don't listen to me just a
star child comedy award winner um
the starcha this next star child is a
bet award winner
comedy award um
what's the donor battle with donald
trump oh so
now first of all it's it's just sad over
there at the
republican gop situation but basically
he's saying
don't donate to the republican party
donate to me and my super pac
and he calls them rhinos republican in
name only and so
he's basically defunding them great
i mean fantastic okay all right like to
me it's like
that's your own what do you what
it's it's what did you guys think was
gonna have it's
it's donald trump donald trump's at the
wrong time like
what did you think was gonna he he he
can't not ruin things
right he has to he that's just what he
does
he's like yes he can't
lindsey graham was right but it was five
years ago
so it's a shame uh
old lindsey graham is crying right now
lady g geez
he's d he's texting people on grinder
saying that he made some mistakes it
reminds me of the
end of the movie where the bad guy who
conjured the spirit
gets stuck with him it's like not me
like it's like
yeah what did you did you did not think
he
he's incapable and the only thing that
can happen he just has to
die from old age or or whatever the [ __ ]
or whatever
some i mean his dad lived at like 87 but
um
and what but was did have mental uh
health decline
um it was very sad to watch i watched
the whole thing 93 i said 87
93 even worse 93 fred trump that's two
more
um oh okay so
well let's talk about pierce morgan
first of all i
called it what did you say well remember
i said you know and what's up with
[ __ ] pierce morgan [ __ ] this guy yeah
and then we had a whole thing about well
i just said like he's just a broadcaster
that he's a reliably white supremacist
broadcaster
yeah i asked you why does somebody like
him still live it's just cockroaches of
the entertainment industry they
even though he gets canceled and
everybody on every side has hated him
yeah how does that person live and you
just said
does no morals he didn't get fired no he
didn't fight
that's what i'm saying he he didn't
he he he is all the [ __ ] i said he's
pierced morgan
baby child he's a baby he walked off he
didn't cancel no no no i was talking
about his
show in america got cancer oh yeah like
i'm just saying he keeps
he finds somewhere to be always yeah oh
he got kicked out of england didn't
wanna be came here yeah we were like
this guy sucks yeah now he's back on
good morning britain
well then he right the day after we
talked about this
he couldn't take the heat he couldn't
take the heat by the weather and and
but that's the thing is when you're
working with uh it's like showbiz rules
where you don't he's the highest paid
person on that
on that set he's kind of the big dog
right so none of them it takes a such an
egregious
thing for them to be able to say hey
[ __ ]
hey look what i found like you what did
you say about this woman
right everyone now is on our is on the
the brown side sort of so they can then
they have
they have the power to shame him off
right i know how to say that i i bet
they were surprised
i think they were floored when he walked
yeah
yeah but come to find out i mean i
didn't realize that
he was just salty that she stopped being
his friend
it's always personal it's so
it's such bad writing like is that in
french
he's gay you know bianca bianco
no i don't think he's gay oh is he no i
think he's married with kids man oh my
bad my bad
i i could be dead wrong but i don't know
you know i don't know things yeah
he got in a fight with gay conversion
therapists uh attica
sounds like he's gay at a at a at a
rally multiple he's been married to
marry in multiple so she wouldn't
[ __ ]
when she leaves he did you see the clip
of him telling the story
yeah and he's like a guy put her in
anything i put her in a cage
right there it's like you know it's like
i can put anybody she calls you escort
her from the door
of the of the pub to the to the black
cab
did you work security for the lady from
suits
yeah i put her in a cab it was so and
then she went on to a party
where where yeah it's about me don't you
see
and i never heard from her again like i
recap it really quick for the listeners
they went for a drink i guess
and then and then he put her they get on
great
and then for an hour and a half to two
hours and then
he put her in a cab which means she got
a cab
uh maybe he hailed it and
at you know which again black hats have
to stop
excuse me and um and then she went to a
party
and uh met harry
and then they and then she never
talked to him again she ghosted him
she's like she ghosted me
um so yeah which is like don't
don't use terminology i think he was
probably he was married at this point
uh i don't know i don't know the ins and
outs
but i wasn't asking you i'm just saying
she's married
like i don't think it was like they were
they had she was staring in suits of
course she was a spring visit to the uk
as if it's like an
official visit she went to wimbledon to
watch
our mutual friend serena williams hey we
spent two hours in a pub she had a
couple dirty martinis
i had a couple of pints we got on
brilliantly
and then i put her in a cab it turned
out to be a habit
i don't know he's right but i don't
think she wanted to [ __ ] him
no ew they're not in the same category
her and him and harry
uh he is uh harry what would you
give harry a number out of ten can i
decline this no i want to know what you
think
if e5 wow okay what do you give pierce
morgan
one okay appears more he's like so
harry is a five out of five and piers
morgan
he has a five out of five uh i like
harry's spirit
oh harry is a person but you gotta you
gotta [ __ ] him so
give him a i'm not saying just look i'm
saying the whole thing oh the whole
thing
yeah eight yeah okay
[Music]
um and uh we got our will play the theme
[Music]
okay and then still a one for the other
guy
piers morgan yeah yeah no what would you
give hillary clinton
don't you you're a [ __ ]
how dare you um hillary clinton
of course the prince harry of america
hillary clinton no the piers morgan of
america well
um that's even now you're the sexist uh
i turn it on you and then what happened
with sharon osbourne and so she
is on the talk and she was like peace
malkin is a good
friend of mine and she was crying
and she said it's not right to cancel
people and
this is not okay and the black cohorts
were just calmly explaining to her
how well he's been pretty misogynistic
and racist and right-wing for a long
time like
he's not the victim in this and i think
one of them got a little
was getting not emotional but she was
getting very passionate and then
sharon goes to the black lady and says
don't you dare cry
you don't have the right to cry i have
the right to cry because it's
my friend and well that was the
sin that did jesus that was one of dr
king's
huge things was giving black people the
right to cry
in public um so when
that happened everyone was like well
stop yelling at your black co-host that
yeah it's your turn to cry and they
should have nothing to cry about
yeah and then the talk is on hiatus
oh interesting who's crying now
now the viewers are crying how are they
going to find
inane chatter where will they turn to
for when they need it's it's 10 a.m you
need a name chatter
where else you're going to turn oh the
chew okay go to the other one
and then apparently then so holly chomp
you ever watch the job
so uh holly robbs and pete who used to
be on the
talk and she said that
sharon used to say behind the scenes
that she was too ghetto for the show
holly was holly was too ghetto which
what are you talking about holly ross
and pete and she
was like well once sharon started saying
that i was too ghetto
uh then i was let go so
i don't know well if holly robinson too
ghetto
i hope she never sees this because
you're
um you were raised in the watts towers
if holly robinson is too ghetto um
jay-z speaking of ghetto
de la ghetto uh jay-z
sold titel he sold
um a title a week or two ago
yes and then last and he also sold
did he sell his did he sell it or it's
like
it's a he sold his i think he sold part
of his equity
already and then sold the rest of his
title equity in the what's the name of
it it's
french but it's like it's called
colloquially ace of spades because
that's a logo
right um i don't know the name but he
sold it to the louis vuitton people
um louis vuitton lvmh one of the
most profitable companies in the world
or something
yeah some weird because it's louis
vuitton it's mostly it's a ton of [ __ ]
hennessy yeah it's tiffany yeah it's
just
what it's
uh yeah it's just so much it's just so
much stuff that everybody consumes
at a high volume uh world's most
viable luxury brand a value sorry uh
valuable we what we did was we put in a
tiny monitor
on our show but it's impossible to read
it's closer
but daniel bought it and we a year and a
half ago and i thought
it's not on my watch will we not will we
let a monitor go to waste
so now we've ruined the show it's a
monitor france
with a monitor that we can't even see we
see that there's a monitor
there's figures on it um will finally
just made it bigger wow
what no one had thought of it's the most
valuable luxury brand
so um anyhow good for
good for oh so here's the argument
though some people are saying
which i wonder you're we should
i think i know what their argument is
and i like it okay
um so the argument is that jay-z sells
his brands and
markets them like buy black people
affordable
people support black business but then
sells inevitably sells them
big that makes the brand big and sells
them to
evil whites so in the end
it can come across is it a black
business still is it did he
leverage black support right
for his own gain and then
sell it's uh you know it's not on the
backs of black people exactly it's not
i i don't think it's a it's a good
argument
and what else can he do
he could never sell it but
that doesn't seem like the right move
also he can use the money to
he can give to black stuff and he can
also support
quietly support new black businesses and
just get it to a point where
whites come and give them one and
everybody gets to pay out
the ideally at a certain point the
payout
um helps more than just him
meaning he can take a company and co-own
it with a number of black people
then a number of black people get the
money right um
like i i'm i'm i'm
it's one of those like what are you
gonna do it's not ideal but it's
the way business is it's kind of like it
it's kind of ideal
if he has a billion dollars he ain't
spending on white people
right and he's not gonna support white
people and he's not gonna so black
people
are gonna benefit from it whether it's
this check or not
i think make as much of a profit as you
can well that's chris used to do this
joke about like
the if white i mean it was back before
anyone owned it but
like if black people owned a bullet
company
or a gun company it would be a problem
or uh it was alcohol i think the joke
was alcohol but
but the the white people can sell
anything it's like well good for him
right whereas if it's it black people
it's like then you get into the morality
of like is this good for black people
and all the
[ __ ] that uh white people never have to
deal with
whiteness pretty great
marry into it if you can and if you
just don't not one specific family
i realized afterwards that
buckingham palace is
the real white house it's the locust of
white supremacy yeah
everyone was conquering but it was
spanish spanish
and portuguese who any
great white men will tell you not white
right
british were the like the main
they invented which is why i thought it
was wrong
i wasn't saying what i was i was
wondering what is
i know england's racist but like what is
the it was about
the firm and the this and that but i
think
part of their that thing and the reason
why we were like
uh finding it difficult to define it it
part of its mystery is part of its brand
yes that's why when you have one tidbit
the [ __ ] world's on fire
because there is mystery because you
don't i heard when she said i went to hr
to get help
yeah hr yeah there's a royal hr yeah
you know so i think there is it is so
shrouded in mystery
i don't even think there was a royal
agent it was like just some ladies
i mean it was it was somebody who's like
okay and then
also couldn't help her no which proves
she was an agent
and it proves hr i only never princes
kings and
queens right and print and princesses
sorry about that duchess
um so i think that's what we do
understand though
is that like you're saying you're right
it is the
origin of what it's like the it's the
big bang of white supremacy
so not like she should be
like she shouldn't have been surprised
but it's i the more i thought about it i
was like
i kind of thought it when we were
talking about it but
it they started the slave
i talked to jimmy carr about it today
like they started the slave trade
they invented it they were basically
like the way that
like the silk road was they were the
bizarre
yeah i know before they talk about it no
of course we talked about all this stuff
uh jimmy's a little more passionate no
no i you
because i would you were misunders i
didn't i wasn't saying
they're not racist what i'm saying is
you just were like what is it what is it
i just want to know what it it like
they can't it they
invented white supremacy right
but i'm still wondering what is the firm
but
we could also not know what the [ __ ] it
is and still understand
all of the terrible racist things
attached to it and understand that
who's surprised that they're worried
about the skin color of this child yeah
like it was just he also told me who who
it was
shut the [ __ ] up give me that answer
right after this
jimmy he's a good boy everybody knows
that um
uh stacy dash no longer racist
good for us yeah
i was manipulated no she's still a
baddie
she's so hot without even with the even
with the
she's got pierce morgan's personality
basically you know in a in a
in a mine's body i mean she's
so hot but the problem is every girl
grew up wanting 72 years old stacy
every girl wanted to grow up being devin
from clueless yeah
it was the one time when you were
playing with a mixed group of girls
where
somehow somehow somehow race didn't have
to do
but when i wanted to be ginger spice i
had to be scary spice
i was like well why can't i be gentle
what if you had wanted to be
alicia silverstone nobody wanted to be
alicia silverstone everyone fought to be
devil halfway to find
everyone thought to be devin yeah yeah
everyone i think it was no
i don't know it's so long ago i don't
know who yeah dane
darren dana limbaugh everyone wanted to
be her
in clueless regardless of race everyone
wanted to be
right were you allowed to be like
no no i was like sit over there with
alicia silverstone
this is uh spice girl's rules yes no
uh everybody wanted to be lisa turtle it
was a spice world spice
uh yeah the uh
thai was it no no tai was no tai was the
girl died
britney murphy it was dionne dion yes
everybody that
i would argue that clueless
has one of the best black jokes i've
ever seen
in televised history
she walks in on donald faison getting
his head shaved and he goes
i'm keeping it real she's like
it's so [ __ ] funny and i don't know
who wrote it i maybe amer heckling wrote
it i kind of think there's probably no
way
there might that might have just been
but it's one of the best
big big movie [ __ ]
very black joke and
fantastic if you think about it the
undertones were
like they thought that dude was is he
gay no he's not gay
um or uh no the step
not no the guy she goes on a date with
and
and she she he's like take a coat and
she brings the
no he's like the person i don't know the
plot that well was it that's not a lot
it's not a deep plot i know i remember
she went on a date and then rod walked
down the steps
no not red there's another guy that was
uh like a very beautiful looking guy
and she was like i love him so much and
he ended up being
uh gay melton no no not elton
ellen was the one that like tried to
[ __ ] her right and
left her and then she left christian
there we go and left her at the
elton left her at the clown the clown
liquor in the north hollywood
him oh okay sure sure it just was
like a luke uh the jason priest captured
everybody was like there's the persian
mafia there's the like asians there's
this there's that it was it's a it's a
very sophisticated movie for it's
obviously like a roommate remake of jane
austen or whatever but
um it's
you watch it she amy heckerling made
clueless and fast times at richmond high
which are like oh are you serious
yeah please just keep making high school
i know i
did but yeah it's a long story is it
yeah because she also made look who's
talking
i love look who's talking no no i'm not
saying it in a bad way i'm saying
uh
you know we'll start at the beginning uh
fast times i mean that's that's her
opener
it's so good which is like [ __ ] johnny
dangerously a michael keaton movie don't
i think
when you're 10 you think it's good it's
a funny he does like a
like look here see he does like a 50s
sort of
gangster character like the whole movie
uh then
look is talking a killer and probably
i'm
betting a a gold mine for her
gold mine and then um low over
less than 90. she did like all the look
who's talking she did the sequel
spin-off baby talk and then clueless
clueless but then she did night of the
raspberry
oh that was so stupid but it was good i
mean the night of the roxbury's
[ __ ] got some hilarious [ __ ]
and then she just couldn't she wasn't
allowed to do movies again
she was she was she was uh one of my
self
she was on my block in director jail
she saw myself she's myself my monkey
snoring
um so wait are you only as good as your
last movie you certainly are
damn i mean in her case i think there's
some
other factors but that i
am not at liberty to speak about okay
but
uh you know not too much when i told you
about it you were like
what there's a person that directed fast
times and clueless
and she's alive and a woman like she
must be getting
a million scripts a day or million
opportunities a day but
how old is she that's another
if you're coming to hollywood don't be
older or a woman
um 66 is not out of the window of
it's not like amazing but there are 66
year old
male directors male directors ivan
reitman comes to mind
who who doesn't work a ton but
people are like [ __ ] did ghostbusters
so
um we're gonna give him a you know
i haven't 6 74. so that's kind of
significantly older yeah
um amy heckling rest
in power um
gone too soon uh
don't remember what got us there stacy
dash got us there
what do we make of somebody changing
uh is it changing or is it so this isn't
as lucrative this is not lucrative for
me anymore i don't
at all trust her because she said she
changed after
january 6 which is like i gotta say
stacy it's a little late
um she doubled down so hard and so many
points i mean i would stalk her
instagram
everything was it just appears morgan of
like
i'm getting attention here yeah this is
where i'm getting attention this is
where i'm getting money this is
who's responding to me so i'm just going
to double down
so to all of a sudden be like i'm no
longer racist
yeah like how it was how did you do that
it was like
i remember she'd make a killing teaching
it
i know honestly like teach it if it's
real
you're listening yeah of course she's
listening
um yeah teach how to not be racist
it just reminded me of those ricky lake
shows where
they would interview the white
supremacist and they go hang out with
black family he's like i'm no longer
racist yeah
no come on yeah
so george floyd's family got
uh uh a civil settlement
which i don't remember it ever happening
before the criminal trial but
i guess they didn't do a trial they just
settled before they out of court before
it even got to that
i think though sometimes with the
municipal ones they kind of just
what price do you want yeah no okay what
about this
you know yeah um now
what's your what's what are your
thoughts on this
what was the highest that's ever been
paid out so congratulations
no i'm just saying it was
it's nice to read a story that doesn't
make your blood boil as much as usual
because a lot of the times
when stories don't gain as much traction
as this one it's like they got a
50 000 yeah when they
and they got a bill to a street cleaning
bill to clean up the
brains of your loved one you know a lot
of the time it feels like that
um so i didn't feel that
but i don't know it's like
good i mean i hope it's like hopefully
it's good horrible news
yeah i hope it helps i hope it gives
stability to everybody in his life and
maybe it can help yeah
maybe it has truly is a settlement um
and you hope that you hope that
the it it sort of trickles down
meaning the cop i guess
it's because it's a civil settlement if
it were a business you'd go hey
[ __ ] i can't afford these
settlements
because it's a police force of a
municipality
there is the mayor who's elected in
four-year windows
i'm assuming can't really be like hey
you [ __ ] i can't
so i don't know what the and there also
seems to be a revolving door in terms of
police chiefs just going to another city
yeah and
well the good thing about this is
if it sets like a new precedent or
maybe i don't know what how case law
works with civil court but
at least it's a standard like at this
level
this there's a new high standard set you
know
so maybe i mean i just think there's
no way to battle racism
how we want but uh getting someone
money is how money and insurance are
very weirdly helpful ways to do that
there are
ways to because i bet it is an insurance
i bet they have to be insured
for the municipality has to be insured
for
uh [ __ ] like this for sure that's why i
mean we talked about before some cops
who just behave so badly it's like you
gotta retire
yeah because we can't afford yeah we
can't afford our you're too
great so people don't like it
but i think insurance money and
insurance historically is a good way to
you know tailor behavior in general like
they were saying if the
if insurance basically doesn't um
want to ensure these houses out
in the like i don't know boondocks of
california then they're essentially then
no one's really going to live outside
because of the forest fires because they
don't have enough money to
you know so i just think everything is
so related
that just get them where it hurts
yeah my my worry is
that they go like the defense attorney
is like your honor we gave him 27
million dollars
now yes
we did kill but it's 27 million and
it's it's like at one it's a once a m
an admission of guilt and a
you think it's gonna be like come on let
him go no
but it signals to black people
like we [ __ ] paid them
like sorry derek chovin's not going to
go to jail but black people
come on down you don't deride that much
when we find a medicine this guy is so
expressive i'm talking about people this
is how i talk to black people
um look uh yeah they don't
you know what i mean like it's it's like
it's it's softening the blow a little
bit
do you think he's going to get he's
going to catch a case
or get rid of you i don't know what's
more likely in light of the settlement
a guilty plea or a guilty conviction or
an innocent conviction or
innocent finding i don't know
i don't i truly have no idea and i don't
they i know they moved it
they want to get a you know impartial
jury so they're moving the
trial to outer space it will be
it will be outer space will not be human
beings
it will be a space mammal of some kind
and good luck to the space mammals um
okay speaking of death
okay vanessa bryant
won she won the right to
release the names of the cops who
released leaked pictures of kobe yes
victory she's rich so i feel like
mystery
uh yeah good why why not [ __ ] this
yeah release the names we release names
all the time of
the cops release things leak information
all the time
somehow they should be protected why
also sickos
[Music]
it's a good time to listen to the
russian prison
um look we got the songs guys just give
us the stories get all the pots um
[Music]
yeah yeah it seems seems small
yeah it seems uh
like beside the
so beside the point that it's come fully
around
to next it's it's it's like okay
yeah i guess if you're i don't know it
just
i'm not i don't not defending the cops
at any i don't give a i i don't
especially
care i don't know if justice is served
if it feels like
it will make cops less uh
likely to leak in the future
i wonder if that's her i wonder what her
her motives are it must be something
we're not privy to because the fact that
she's like
okay well i'm gonna go ask a cord to
help me then
maybe we could put two and two together
maybe they were like you can't release
you know i don't know i feel like she's
just
morning and upset and pissed off and
he's like
okay oh you not gonna i heard she's
releasing the names
first commercial of the oscars she's
gonna unveil the names
and it's gonna be pretty great uh no but
i but so she got it so now when is she
gonna release them
you know that's what it's like what's
what's the what is the
in some ways i almost feel like she's
there was a uh after 9 11 there was an
onion headline
uh america looks for someone to punch
and basically that's what she it seems
like she's
going through where like she's like
okay so my husband was
killed so every like if she could
sue the mountain she would yeah like
every everyone's getting some
yeah [ __ ] everyone like just [ __ ]
i don't yeah but i don't i guess i don't
have a problem with it i don't have a
problem i don't have a problem
i guess i can't believe how ambivalent i
am about it
okay i just like to show you my
ambivalence i love it
um now who's this person
oh this is interesting keeping up with
the team so alexia mccammond
who is a uh
you'll recognize her she's on axios on
hbo okay
yes i choose um it's a weird photo but
she looks kind of familiar
um she's on axios on hbo she's on msnbc
all the time
okay she just got appointed the
chancellor of teen vogue
editor of teen vogue uh then
old tweets
were not surfaced cause they never went
away and she'd already apologized for
them
prior to this situation yes and she
was allowed on um
on all of the stuff images um
[Music]
outdone by asians this is november
8th of 2011.
um she's now 29 so this is when she was
uh 19. outdone by asians hashtag what's
new
okay i love it i don't know what she's
talking about but already very funny
um now googling how not to wake up with
swollen asian eyes
no that was okay i don't i'm losing the
premise
but she was outdone by asians
outdone by asian i don't know what that
means well
give me two out of ten on my chem
problem
cross out all my work and don't explain
what i did wrong
thanks a lot stupid asian ta you're
great there we go
this is not there we know that's that
there's that marrow i was chewing a bone
i was like why am i chewing this bone
oh delicious pay dirt um
stupid asian ta no and then
somebody responded months later
with something and then and then alexi
wrote she was like an old asian woman
l-o-l-o-l-l what's this
person's problem she was uh asian
college and she's being an agent i don't
i
that's the weird thing is i don't
associate i i don't
i guess my racism
that just seems like this lady's
different
who's the lady uh old asian lady old
asian ta
stupid asian ta it's like what does that
mean
like i'm not saying she's i just mean
like what does it be an asian have to do
with it
yeah that's why it feels but that's what
i don't understand like when people go
like
what are you implying other than
asians are different and bad
in this case it's just we i i get like
blanks are blank i get understanding
like stereotypes
this is
but i but asian people have different
shaped eyes than
do you know what i mean like that that
helps get into it
eugenics see black never bred
please sit down you don't have the right
to cry i have the right to cry
um i yeah i just don't even
what a she now having said that she
apologized for it two years ago
she's still advancing because she got
the new job at teen vogue
um and then but what happened was which
is a whole other
then do a whole thing on asian hatred
and say i was part of it and look it's
like i'm
not a i don't consider myself a raise a
prison just don't give an asian person
to cover because you need sales
okay no no i listen to me you you got to
have sales
somebody by the way trayvon texted me
that
somebody was working uh the guy from the
batch i was working with
with a race racial counselor and
trayvon's like if that's not the neil
brennan sitcom
[Laughter]
it's i know but it's too [ __ ] true
it's like so funny it's yeah i also had
a very funny sitcom idea based on the
george floyd thing
that i wanted wow that's hilarious i
know it seems impossible
i'll explain you off now off the air
okay it's too funny for the air sorry
guys
what do you like what do you do with
this
what there's a couple things here i
spoke to a friend of mine yesterday who
gave somebody a recommendation
okay and he was like who he was giving
somebody the recommend he talked to the
person he gave the recommendation to
and he's like who wouldn't give you a
recommendation
and she and the woman was like uh
gen z and millennials are really petty
about um vouching
but also not while on out vouch she's
don't hire her so her staff
17 people or something on teen vogue
stepped up today
to i don't know if they said like you're
not allowed to
she can't be hired or whatever well
could you
could you uh look up uh teen vogue staff
uh invoke staff alexi
um on friday kind of in a
more than 20 teen vogue staff members
the [ __ ] up thing is in my head
they're all teenagers even though
they're i know i'm like
pointed to an anti-asian racist and
homophobic tweets that mccain posted in
2011 that surfaced over the weekend
they were especially concerned given the
recent spat of violence against asian
americans
we built our outlets reputation as a
voice for just and change
we take immense pleasure and eating
disorders we take immense pleasure
in not vogue and not teen vogue big vote
take immense pride in our work and in
creating an inclusive environment
in a moment of historically high
anti-asian violence and amid the ongoing
struggles of the lgbt community
um we at the staff of team vogue fully
reject those sentiments
so i guess they didn't say that she
shouldn't be
by the way she was 17. so when she wrote
that when she wrote it yeah
um i just think you know what
why not hit it head on
and make an issue really highlighting
asian americans asian
everything that we kind of turned a
blind eye to i feel like in this country
hatred we love it when it's
from white to black we love white
against black hatred it sells we get
really excited we get really upset
people take sides for no reason
um i mean people take white people's
side for no reason
it's just like it's violent well regret
we're supreme
uh yeah yeah so i don't know i just
think
there's a way to accept that you were
being a dumb
she's not being asked to fire she's
they're not saying fire
and they're not i wonder if this is
gonna affect editorial decisions in the
future when people that uh
uh rebuked or publicly are pitching
stories
and she's the editor anyhow i'm sure
won't get personal at any point
i just think they can turn this lemon
into lemonade
of course they can't i guess it's like
how do we adjudicate it's how do we
adjudicate something that's already been
educated she apologized two years ago
did the staff why didn't the staff do
the asian issue
before this you know it's a bit like
well you guys weren't doing it and maybe
they were i don't i don't know
i don't know what i'm talking about i
something's not even fishy
just i feel like there's a way that
somebody doesn't
have to it's just one of the reasons
that nobody yeah thankfully i don't
think it is
uh that her career is going to end you
because she is a
she's a woman of color it's do you know
what i mean she's a woman of color
those tweets though i mean like i don't
i don't know i don't remember sometimes
it's hard to remember yourself at 17
you're like 16 and how i said so much
stupid [ __ ] but
i wasn't very racial you know it was
just really stupid
um yeah i used to say gay oh
i mean and then i understood that was
bad it was just i'm equating gay to
something very negative
and then a teacher of mine was like just
sat me down
like you got us like not me
super gay okay no i like the the class
and just yeah i don't know just started
putting it in our heads why
why are we saying that as something
negative you're not saying that's gay
and it's positive we were all saying it
in a pejorative way so i don't know once
that
clicked in our heads all of us were like
you know so i don't so if someone
villainized me and every single person i
went to school with
yeah oh the i mean like i said the
amount of
times my brother's [ __ ] was
the one i mean it was just unequivocally
that was the word constantly it sounded
like
a gay bashing in our backyard oh my god
just not i mean just in that yeah like i
don't know where you [ __ ]
nobody would say [ __ ] at r or like
yeah
at r at my level or we said gay
now i wouldn't even think to describe
something as that it's so
bad feeling inside yeah but and also
weirdly enough we have these weird psas
storing hillary duff that we're like and
don't say
gay quit it i don't know do you remember
those then she said you
then she called you guys the n-word okay
um
no but i just think you know i don't
know there's she's 17. i didn't realize
she was 17.
yeah because she said ta which is a
college thing yeah it sounds like she
was in college um
yeah there's hillary um
whenever i hear like hillary duff
whenever you were in high school when
hillary duff was used as a tool
and i'm like they play it play it's just
a psa it's fine
do you like this top so gay
really yeah it's totally gay you know
you really shouldn't say that
pause it and then hillary duff walks
looks at and goes you're right it is gay
and that's the name that's the end of
the commercial
kneel say what well say that something's
gay when
you mean it's bad it's insulting
what if every time something was bad
everybody said oh that's so
girl wearing a skirt as a top oh you are
those are cute jeans though when you say
that's so gay do you realize what you
say
knock it off you miss the best part
knock it off yeah so
sometimes you just some people need to
do the right psa to come along
no i was i'd stop before that but it
really meanwhile the poor asian
manufacturers of skirt
top tops
skirt skirt tops tops of skirts tops
um stops stops
um but i think it's also like hey
everyone let's just
hey admit i was [ __ ] up yeah
hers is so i was nobody
i grew up with was ever saying someone
was gay in a personal way
i think that's not the most important
you know i don't deserve a pat on the
back
but saying
like stupid hca is like
yeah i don't it's like what is so stupid
ta
cbd everyone can get behind and then
that the fact that they're asian
what difference does it make it's bad
racism if you're going to be racist guys
this is part of neil brennan's
okay racial counseling be
s make it with a point
thank you and a stereotype an existing
stereotype
from hopefully at least from the 1800s
that's that's what i'm asking for i
don't think we've met i'm neil
um doc watch well
watch a dark watch
uh did you watch biggie i
kind of promise okay you did watch it i
did not yeah because i get
i've seen so many biggie docs and all
that stuff
that they make me sad yeah
and it feels you know what's gonna
happen
yeah so i don't know how
was the journey to through the
documentary different
than anything no it's not i'll say that
i don't think it's great
um it's not an amazing documentary but
was there a reason why they made it like
is there new i think his
mom was more involved and
uh i
think that netflix is
does well with black programming like i
think like yeah black icon documentaries
i think are
do well on netflix so um
i don't know that for a fact but i'm
assuming so uh
so it's
the here's the thing that it made me
realize guys
like him he
looked like a [ __ ] stick-up
kid all the 80s rappers
by the time i saw them on television
looked like run dmc was like wearing a
costume
and they seemed old like run dmc even
though they were probably
late 20s when they hit they seemed like
they all looked old for their age um
ll was like sort of like sculpted and
moist lips and [ __ ] uh
iced tea iced tea seemed like whatever
crimes he did
weren't going to affect me
biggie looked like he
just robbed somebody and it was to see
him on television
uh regular just talking and rapping and
like the lifestyle and all that stuff it
was it's like patrice one time said
nwa scared the [ __ ] out of him when he
saw nwa he was like
holy [ __ ] like
like emir questlove said the same thing
he was like who the
[ __ ] are they they were scared like
whole i gotta stay away from them
um that's really funny that's like and
also he was like
so [ __ ] young she's like 20.
so you just didn't see guys like that
on television or talking
the amount of talking i watched tupac do
in like mtv interviews and [ __ ] he was
on tv
constantly if you turn on mtv there was
gonna be a two box story
an incredibly young guy so it was more
about
like that picture of him and
tupac that guy didn't exist culturally
right before before
no no on in television oh yeah like he
wasn't like
we're gonna cut to a guy who looks like
he'll fight you
now he will you
you might get in trouble now like he was
and he was selling drugs while he was
recording so like
it wasn't the image match the even the
his early photos were shot on the corner
once you get into the crown stuff that's
like second album
but when he first hit that whole
like fleet of rappers including wu tank
land which were like
they beat up the source writers they
literally
beat the writer up and the photographer
it's
so funny like they did now it wouldn't
it was like in the 80s it was like all
very like corporate media
and then there's this window where it's
before it's like
hip-hop journalism is new all these guys
are new
and they're
they're all like grew up in the
lady like were selling drugs
in a way that i just don't didn't think
krs one did
the generation before it like there was
something churchier about the generation
before them
and even if it wasn't directly church so
it was just watching these guys and
realizing like
wow that was a because and by the way
now it kind of wouldn't happen
like that there's a
culturally like the guy pops mo or pop
smokes
but but the baby duh baby and little
babies
to babies uh
would be more controlled to me it's like
chris talked about
how late public enemy was not sorry live
in their career
it was like 91
their best album came out in 88 yeah
so just the like white people were so
far behind
and just something about
this class was like
wow these guys are real like street
dudes
perfect well yeah i mean especially when
you watch the
wu tang doc yes
i you really got the feeling like
okay yes we are we're living our lives
yeah we're going to try to
better hope this check gets here
you don't want to be here when i realize
that the check's not coming
because then i'm going to have to do
crime because that's what i was doing
but like they were
still doing drugs selling drugs
everything throughout
the greatest albums the greatest records
yeah so you know the like disparity
between
the artists and what they're rapping
about was so small
which is it yeah it wasn't even there
wasn't there's nothing
there's it's it is that yeah i sold
drugs then i went and made a song about
it
yeah and i'm on drugs and i and i'm yes
sometimes i'm on them then i'm gonna go
back and it's all one
continuous thing so uh rotten rhymes
uh funk infused beets
hip-hop in new york that that's what i
sound like to people
when i talk about hip-hop um but it
may and incredibly young
and at the end toward the end they show
video of
jay-z sitting with him yeah and
it's not the first time i realized it's
the distance that these guys traveled
is so
admirable it's like miraculous
it's like so miraculous and it's
something that like i tune into and tune
out of because like if i cj now it's
like
you're not thinking about no rc problem
but the thing is he's not either no he's
thinking about millions and millions
he's thinking about lvmh and popping
bottles but
that's really impressive yeah it's like
uh
you know slumdog million like there's
like these things of like get
getting out of that situation is a
[ __ ] miracle yeah i heard will smith
say that one time that that
that's the thing that africans
in the world are impressed by african
americans by like
how did you get how did you take over
the world
from there and they're like i rapped
um i'm charismatic and i rapped so uh
shout out to um the various uh
kings who have um
who have traversed uh impossible
distances impossible it's in
it's impossible and they did it
you see any donkeys i
okay i've been sucked in by the
great british takeoff the great british
bake office
how long did it take how many episodes
well there's eight seasons
and i'm i'm stuck i got i can't get out
of the
great finish bake off well i'm not ma
how long did it take you to get stuck
in the dough you couldn't like two
episodes two
episode one and a half of one two
and it's funny because you go back i'm
watching episodes from like 2012.
all these people are famous now they're
famous british people now but they're
just
on some very famous in what way
i don't know the show is so endearing
because everything's like
okay and we're gonna make uh your
genoise sponges and it's like hey no
the the syrup's not taking it's so
delicate of a reality show you know and
i realize that it's so [ __ ] charming
because it's very calm and quiet and not
american if it was american you'd have a
guy like
i'm gonna [ __ ] kill it you know
nobody has an ego
when they win the episode i can't
believe it
like everything is so self-deprecating
and
i don't know how i made it and there's
something
so charming about it it isn't a battle
of this
it's it's also they're baking so it's
not i mean that's that keeps them humble
of it
yeah it's like sing-sing like yes like
i'm going it's it's tasteful it's tasty
it's like dignified
like no it doesn't say cooking isn't but
there's no there's no
it's there's no room for rot for bravado
right and bro
um there's also they're cooking [ __ ]
from like patisserie like these old
school french things that i've never
heard of any of these desserts
and you know what's [ __ ] up if i watch
something like when i watched the
sopranos i ate so much italian food
while i watch it it just gets
in my psyche uh when i watch the wire i
so much kfc and crap crack
so much i skipped the crack but they
used to eat those like kfc boxes
yeah kfc crabs this [ __ ] show
is making me eat dessert like i don't
like dessert really
but like at some point you're like i
want to try genesis
i have to write something down about the
wire that i'm can't say
oh my god that you need to say it's got
the n word and it needs the n word to be
funny
to talk about okay okay and
i think if they made they made it
american version
i don't think it did that well because
americans
their egos are so inflated and they
do this kind of fake it till you make it
mm-hmm so it's like i'm gonna win i
don't
this whole i'm i just talk myself up to
oblivion
competitive talking [ __ ] kind of the the
british don't have that
and i don't think they would like you if
you did that there i think you'd be
i mean gordon ramsay it doesn't seem
beloved
it's a little love hate but not most
people aren't like him apparently i
didn't know that
no one likes jamie oliver anymore
interesting did you know that he was
always cute
he was cute they hate him because he
came to america started hanging out with
americans
got too much ego they're like don't big
time us all right so
tony woods the great comedian uh
what used to sell drugs in dc
and annapolis he sold crack i'm assuming
in dc in annapolis there's obviously
rivalry turf stuff between dudes who
sell drugs in dc and due to health drugs
in baltimore because they're close
so the wire is about selling drugs in
baltimore and i asked tony woods if he
had ever watched it
at which point he said this to me
why would i watch a show about [ __ ] i
used to rob
which is a very funny thing to say
so funny it's so funny it's like
stop what you're doing and think about
how funny that is
so [ __ ] funny so funny it's so funny
that's like the way tony's funny
that he could never capture on stage
it's like it's like
so [ __ ] funny um it's
there are a lot of comics that people
never know how
how funny they are yeah because there is
this
i don't know je ne sais quoi that
certain comics have and certain comics
don't of being able to
capture their special [ __ ] and like
yes say it over and over again and have
the audience get it
the exact same way dudes they would have
gotten it at work
if they work with you yeah i know but if
you get it right
you get eight hundred million dollars
then you're neil
no you're not me uh you're you you're
very good
oh no no i'm saying you get
sandler ellen uh you get a billion
dollars
you don't think you could be that no why
uh what's that catholic in you no i
because i it's
it's uh i had this conversation with
ellen one time where
we were in one of her houses okay and i
said this is a really nice house like uh
how much was it well you answer that
yeah of course
this is what people like and don't like
about me um
and she said i don't remember what she
said 11 million or
13 something and uh just look up her
real estate
holdings they're all over 10 million
bucks and by the way don't look it up
perfect house like perfect yeah and like
two bedrooms not far from sunset like
two bedrooms
that's what i'm saying it's perfect it's
perfect it's a perfect house
pool but not too it's right off sunset
and beverly hills
she sold it and uh and
i was like i would love to have a house
here but i don't
i'll never have 13 million dollars to
spend in a house and she goes yeah you
will and i go
no i won't i was trying to explain her
like you know how much money you have to
make
to have a 13 million dollar house right
you got to make 35. you have to have
35 million dollars easy you gotta have
35 million
and then think about what you have to do
to make 35 million dollars because
and then you go well netflix you get 20.
all those people already had
[ __ ] they already had a 13 million
yeah they already had
i don't know what dave doesn't but yeah
maybe he does
he could but yeah he it's yeah it's not
for lack of
you actually can't spend that kind of
money in ohio
you can't you can't find it buy the
whole state you're like i
all right uh dave it's uh it's 140
bedrooms and it's still only a million
six um
yeah i'm not saying it in a self-pitying
way there's just like a
there's it's just that i'm not like a
super bowl person do you know what i
mean like i'm not my act isn't super
bowl
that's just not my core well
if but it's i'm obviously very funny but
if you make
a show right there's other means to get
that
i feel like you are such a good writer
at heart that like
that's why you're a good comic that's
why you've written on good [ __ ]
so but that
that portion of it is
uh so magically lucky
that
i wouldn't you're not banking possibly
you're not like it's like and
and i and i know what it would be like
to do
yeah uh it's like
i'm not gonna say who but he said when
he was doing his
sitcom he just thought this is gonna be
incredibly hard
for like nine years but
if i can make it if i make it through
this
you know so many famous people i'm like
hmm i there's a clue in the length
i thank you it was i
found blindfilm what uh you'll never
i'll never tell okay
oh this is a book that we talked about a
few weeks ago
um the thing about
paving over pools so black people can
use them
and basically hurt the white people as
well okay
it's like cutting your office yeah um
she was actually gonna call the book to
spite your face
uh she didn't call it she called it the
sum of us um
meaning s-u-m uh and the her name's
heather mcgee she was on franken's
podcast i heard i just wanted to like
state clearly who she was in case people
want to read it uh
book how is it i haven't read it okay i
just heard it on
on uh frank are you gonna read it yeah
um
a lot of uh boring uh stats next week
no i think she i i think it's good and
and it was the podcast was great if you
don't if you just want to listen to
that let's go to the emails
[Music]
wednesday listener here uh not quite
topped here getting there
uh
i'm curious if i can think of how to
phrase this question correctly
um neil what income level would you be
willing to
switch places uh with a black man
and conversely um binky what
level what would the cutoff level be to
switch places with
a white woman obviously this scenario
assumes you would happily give up your
racial identities so you know putting
that aside
i'm just curious about where the
intersection
of race and class lives
and how much of it is
to do with money class and wealth great
great question uh he's i'm gonna he's
gonna be
one of my first hires at my racial
counseling firms
um we'll talk about the headband
he looks like a star child he does look
like a bit of a star trek he looks like
one of my
plant friends um that's a great question
go ahead now to quote rock
fame is the greatest gift god can give a
black man
so it's you could be a millionaire
black person but if you're
uh not known you'd have to
d you'd have to be one of those like
flashy like
put yourself in your own commercials
kind of guys to get
you'd have to take the money and put it
aside to make yourself locally famous
so we're already over let's put it over
a million
okay but i would once i had the money
i would make myself locally famous i'd
make horrible commercials
with me and the star like tell him yeah
donald center
yeah what's my name what's my black name
uh
nico nico tell him nico sent you no nico
there are no black end names that well
you be careful well there's one great
one
no neil well all right what
nate nate dawg is slacker than
yeah but nico's blacker than nate
with nico nico like miami that's not
miami black
yeah all right we'll go with nate i
don't love nate though but nate
tell him nate sencha tell him nico nate
sent you
aka nardo
black nardo tell black nardo sent you
and
neil is a wigan
that's it that's a very good question
that's a good one um
oh i don't think there's
an amount you you have to
oh i have to well it's not uh you didn't
oh i thought it was would you if
you could be you have to what uh what's
the what's the
so they're saying you couldn't they
couldn't pay you enough to be white
i don't okay so if we're gonna play
along
if let me rephrase it because i don't
think it's like
pain you'll be what it's it's at what
income level
do you believe your quality of life
would sustain itself as a white woman
and i don't mean your car you're
anything i'm talking about that you're
the feeling inside you
if i was a white woman i would want a
considerable amount of income because i
would i feel like there's
a type of good you can do as a white
person
that i'm not waiting for one
a non-white person can't like i would
i don't you know i don't i don't have a
great answer but i would say
i'd need to have a net worth of i would
want to give so much back into
communities
so i'd have to have a considerable
amount of net worth because that's what
i would
if we just woke up i'm like yeah whoo
freaky friday yeah
um i would just
completely devote myself to community
service so
no one wants a poor community service
person i think you're underestimating
the
the 50 the power what
the the way whiteness dulls
your sense of privilege so once i get in
i'm just like once you get in you'll be
like
oh you know what hey you guys i could
write that
um shoes
white uggs a water bottle a new water
bottle
i spent i'm a i do plant medicine um
that's a great question though great it
makes sense
makes you think it makes you it makes me
respect the
listeners they get it the listeners
again especially when i'm reading how
many are giving a [ __ ] for saying
tuesday listening
tuesday listener is so funny it's so
funny uh and also this is the kind of
guy that you would kind of you wouldn't
assume
he wouldn't even thinks about this stuff
no let alone
you know has it has an insight
yeah describe them for people he's like
a white guy he's got like a bob
like a eddie vetter kurt cobain bob and
he's got it
in what can only be described as a uh
burgundy brownish head wrap that you'd
see
on a black woman uh on a sitcom
okay in a night scene like would you
come in here
she'd be wearing something like that i
don't even know what you call that this
looks burlappy to me no no i'm not
saying fabric i'm just saying the the
shape you know it looks like one have
you ever seen those white muslims
yeah and they wear white linen muslims
go ahead
yeah the ones with the orange beards
we've talked about yeah yeah yeah no no
those are sikhs we only talked about no
the orange muslim we talked about orange
orange orange guys
uh muslim guys especially have
afghanistan
paint their [ __ ] they paint their
beards orange every time i see it
because it's so crazy that it took off
it's a power to [ __ ]
how infectious culture is no matter how
stupid it is so funny
anyways yeah yeah it's it's that guy but
uh no he seems nice and i like his
mid-century modern staircase
interesting so there you go goodbye
interesting i should say you've got me
hello sir neil and lady banks lstnre
my name is robert and i grew up in
a household uh when i was watching
the three mic special again on repeat a
couple of nights ago
i saw the bit about
what you define as a true narcissist
and also your experience growing up in a
household of 10 kids
and how those factors can interplay
with one another i'm the youngest of
five uh my father
was i would not say a violent alcoholic
although uh when i came home from the
hospital one time after a bike accident
and he did throw a lamp at me
so the question becomes that'll teach
you relative to your own experience
how does one understand
their value their worth
and how they're meant to
coexist in a world that's defined by a
prism
of i'm not worthy
you have to fight for everything you
have it's
you know time to scrap anything you have
to say on the thought would be
much appreciated thanks for your time be
well
uh great question i'm going to be one of
those people who says great question now
an interview it's a great question
and because i read i read charisma books
um you have to
ignore that person's reality
that person is a
sick person and their
perception of the world can be right
you know they understand left from right
and they can follow directions and they
can be very
gifted in things and whatever but their
perception
of the people around them
is completely warped to the point where
you have to you have to know that
every time you deal with them yeah you
have to
because otherwise you will get swept up
in
their perception of you it's the the
thing i think i said
on here which is i'm not who i think i
am i'm not who you think i am
i'm who you who i think you think i am
so if i think if you're around someone
who you know
doesn't value you you're not going to
value that's who you are
so you have to divorce yourself from
the the situation it sounds hard
because you travel by bike but
it sounds hard to divorce yourself from
your dad
you just have to know that like they're
they're uh
they're sick person and not like you're
sick just like
they have this thing that distorts their
reality
and you have to be firmer in your
reality
yeah in order to deal with them any
anything you thought no i just like
listening the the the yeah my dad's
narcissist was about
narcissism was about his
his grandeur i didn't
i gotta say there was a weird thing with
my me and my dad where it was
he knew it was like he knew
i was in onto him and couldn't
rarely violent i was i think i've said
it which is i was like the
you know when um in war
officers it's like a different thing and
officers from different
armies will meet kind of socially yeah
um or at least they'll meet it they'll
meet it like
malta whatever that's not but you know
what i mean like
um that's kind of with my dad he was
like
i can't really [ __ ] with you because i
know you know
and they all think you're good so if for
me to
go negative on you would be like
it would be too crazy like they'd be
like
there would be a revolt right i'm i was
there meghan markle
so it was okay sacrifice neil
sacrifice not putting any [ __ ] on yeah
to maintain
kind of like it wasn't even that
explicit it was more just like
he knew that i he knew that i
didn't [ __ ] with him and he and he
didn't entirely disagree with me
interesting about it no
not even close not even a like huh or
like a one-word
word confirmation he told one of my
sisters
this is whatever he told one of my
sisters that i had the highest iq
uh i don't know of the family or the
kids
or something but i'm it's
it's like dave's joke about the white
guy who hangs out with black guys like
that you don't know what that white guy
did to impress the black guys
but it was crazy yeah
it was in that i don't know not like he
was i
i was given good status or it was like
it was still vi
it was still chaotic he was still cold
he was still unloving he was still
tons of other [ __ ] right but there was
an element
of respect toward me
because i was precocious like i was like
wise he would say it's like speaking of
which i told you
how homophobic things used to be yeah in
the in the
he wrote a he would write a christmas
letter every year
and when i started kindergarten
he said this is a direct quote from me
that he put in the christian letter
neil um isn't crazy about
kindergarten and says they sing gay
songs
so if you don't think i've been me
that i would not even like these are
home these are homosexual songs because
they were
they were no but that's really
why would he put that in the comments
because that that you could advertise it
back then
that was funny like
anyhow that was the thing with
but but the narcissist i've dealt with
as an adult you have to divorce yourself
from them
and and not fall into perceiving
yourself through their prism
well you know i feel like we're
we're always on in a in pursuit to
figure ourselves out
like why am i like this way we're also
and we're we also
tried to figure out our parents
especially as we get older
um and i
remember going on like years ago when i
subreddit called raised by a narcissist
and i you're talking to a member oh
i remember but just because i realized
i was not raised by another oh that's
interesting because
it was the stories are rough
anything sticks out or just like a
general
nothing sticks out nothing i can
remember off the top of my head in like
a certain amount of time yeah but
really weird competitive stuff
yeah like my dad was competitive with me
like for sure really
the competitive nature of parents to
children
it's not like i haven't not felt that
but i
i i'm not going to complain when this is
there's an
um never ending an un unlimited amount
of stories
that my jaw's on the floor i think i
think some of the stuff on that web on
that
subreddit are fantastic compounded no
i think that people there's some bipolar
there's some borderline there's some
it's not i think it's like yeah i think
i think it is narcissism with
other [ __ ] okay but competitive
[ __ ] absolutely i don't even remember
that i don't that's
oh i i think if
and when you're raising kids just do not
be competitive
i don't get how someone gets competitive
with a child i don't
i mean i in theory i certainly don't
i i've heard people voice a thing of
getting mad that their kid
is getting a nicer christmas or whatever
there was a
really funny meme about uh
immigrant parents which um comes to
america
to make their children's lives better
and then
guilt children about their better lives
that's like the cuter version of it
right
but it's a it's just a
if you're a narcissist just don't have a
kid now you're probably telling yourself
but i'd be an amazing parent well i
remember one time
specifically i uh went
i had to i was going to persian school
but
uh my farsi was so shitty that i had to
go into the little kid classes
and i remember i was
getting competitive with a five-year-old
i was like how did she [ __ ] know well
that i get because it's like i get that
i almost you genuinely feel
dumb you feel like not i'm not even as
smart as a five-year-old
i get that okay i i felt so embarrassed
by it when you see a five-year-old
snowboarding you're like what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] this kid and you [ __ ]
give him an elbow to the head but
underneath the helmet so it really lands
um goodbye good another good one you've
got mayo banks and the star
child rstn le i've it's been mentioned
that tuesday listeners are the highest
level of listener
and as a dedicated thursday watcher i'd
like to make a case for non-tuesday
listeners still making the top tier
okay for a while i tried to listen on
tuesdays for the immediacy of something
enjoyable
but i felt like i missed so much in the
way you two interact
um i think bianca took a pill during
this
uh podcast because her boobs got a cup
size bigger
as you mate as you may point out
frequently
some of uh communication is toned but 55
of it is body language and it's just
interesting to watch
when neil accuses bianca of being upset
a viewer can see it first because she
avoids eye contact
when bianca has to uh commentate neil's
actions
a viewer can already see that neil is
struggling to tie his
tri bracelet with his teeth lately
viewers have also been able to see your
genuine excitement from celebrity
callers
for me a lot of the energy is lost when
i'm listening
it is just a better overall experience
and worth the wait to watch
um plus as a viewer you can see the very
available sexual energy that you both
bring
the hardest part is having the neil like
discipline
to wait for the full episodes it's like
waiting for ice cream day or
rewarding yourself with masturbation
once you're in for the night
ultimately i don't think it's when or
how you enjoy the podcast that makes you
a top tier listener
but that you are dedicated yes i'm an
active listener ma
i just like to watch too i he likes
that's from a lady that's good yeah it's
i cut her name up but i did know i
thought it felt like a dude
but and then but sometimes i feel like a
dude you know what i mean
and also just to add whenever you accuse
me of being mad
i'm never mad for the reason you're
accusing me
but you're still mad oh yeah but it
won't tell me no no
no it's not that i won't tell you it's
that
it's sometimes
the way you get hung up on things in a
conversation
can be frustrating for me but it's so
minimal that it's not worth
derailing the con no it's just like okay
yeah it's like that it's not like
we need to no i know but i would cat my
friend cat
available sexual energy the corner of
available sexual energy
and i want to say a holder available
sexual energy
let's be honest um and uh
um
has she has very she she's a thursday
watcher
and um which is the highest tier
um she has very funny observations to
the point where
i have the idea of doing having either
doing an
after show with her hilarious because
it's so
[ __ ] funny i because she resolves our
issues
it's very funny well i wouldn't can we
just uh
yes yes but
we got to figure out an after show issue
because it's [ __ ] funny
um but yes no so i'm never ever really
upset i just think sometimes at the
beginning of when we did this podcast
i learned from you that like yeah just
keep moving if you already discuss it
just keep it moving so sometimes
i think my face will look like okay and
it
seems like what's wrong but actually
nothing is
wrong okay for instance cat noticed last
week
i said that you got mad at me for the
racism
thing and she and cat said she was
mad at you for saying you that she
wouldn't know meghan markle was black
unless somebody told her no not at all
so no i was mad that you kept being like
what is it what is it
i don't know [ __ ] i don't know that's
what i'm saying but you're you were
ascribing
a value to i know white people racist
i know england is it is it has a lot of
racist people in it
but when you say like that thing is
racist
and then can't define the thing that's
frustrating to me
okay well then we were both frustrated
um
goodbye neil and bianca i'm a massive
fan of it's all just
love mail now so i listen to several
podcasts on a regular basis
but yours is the one i get most excited
to see pop up
my feet every week so much so that i
need to strenuously object
to the notion that tuesday listeners are
top tier feelers come on
uh uh i'm still uh i'm often still
working on tuesday evening
and even when i'm not i like to save
your show for when i can savor it most
uh full disclosure it's almost always
when i'm doing yard work
oh yard work what a what's a yard
um neil you of all people should
understand the importance of scheduling
the love making
the tuesday listeners want a fast and
furious quickie in the parking lot i'm
trying to take my time
and make a baby i love you both of you
quote it's crohn's
say it the real way i can't goodbye um
uh that's just i just want you guys to
know that we're valuable that's why we
read those letters up front
you've got mail einardo and banks i came
across this amazing
amazing day data visualization called
one pixel wealth that made me realize
that figuring out what to call the
working class
from episode 95 you might not
be the right priority when it comes to
talking about the needs of regular
people in the context of america's
spiraling wealth disparity
uh i challenge you to get through the
entire visualization
challenge not accepted uh the true scale
of wealth of what the media calls
casually the super rich will astound you
it certainly astounded me
i did a i did a uh
daily show thing about how rich jeff
jesus was
i basically says what should we call the
super rich and i have a term
okay morbidly wealthy
great on brand for you on brand for me
the obese i hit them a little
i'm over there i always got it i don't
do that anymore
um morbidly wealthy i think it gets at
the point
they're morbidly wealthy like why would
you need
like what do you what are you doing when
you hear the number
we do it in terms of 90 147
7.5 you know yeah but when
you break it down like
uh he could spend a million dollars a
day
you have to when you do those yeah
that's one
40 times doesn't work if you
even graphs of like you can fit the top
fifth i don't those [ __ ] make me
gloss
one percent has the top yeah
no idea yeah but how how much can he
spend a day
to waste his wealth yeah and it'd still
be excessive to
the average person i love those because
when you hear it it's insane yes it's
like a
million dollars an hour type of person
it's yeah or like
in order to have bezos's money lebron i
don't remember what the stat was
lebron would have to play like for 50
i don't even remember what the [ __ ]
number is it's so
crazy um like 900 years
yeah um
yeah so uh so that's why morbidly
morbidly wealthy good job thank you
sometimes every once in a while um
and that's i'm going to become morbidly
wealthy by coming up with terms like
morbidly wealthy goodbyes that's the
thing is there's not a market
for it now be kind to each other that's
how you make a billion dollars
you've got milanka um i love it i
thought i'd write in regarding your
story about the time
dave told you how black men's penises
are darker
that's like a tmi situation but he said
it so i don't
like do you know what i mean about it
you just need to tmi you just received
like me repeating it feels like am i
betraying a thing he said
but we had it in the cut so um
he also mentioned elbows and knees uh
blackman's paintings are darkening the
rest of their body this was surprising
for me because i was under the
impression that
uh this was the case for dicks across
the board i myself
am sporting multiple shades below the
belt uh
from what from my waist to about my mid
thigh i'm an old pasty bastard but my
junk looks like it's been sunning itself
on a beach somewhere in cancun for the
better part of the summer now
unfortunately for me and my wife
probably
uh that is where the similarities end
anyhow
keep on doing i think it's a blanket
small small
swing and a miss thank you well we got
will a desk everybody if you if
the cues seem a little crisper the
searches are still
this search uh an abomination but the
but the
sound effects have never been better um
uh i've heard the argument this is
another oh wait okay and then there was
another there was another
color i feel like all it's just a
gathering of skin of course it's darker
were you is that why you think it's
darker well everything where there's a
gathering of skin it's darker
hold on let's stop calculating that
would a neck not be a gathering skin
because it's got give
but it is a bit tight and it is kind of
like
it's not it's not it's resting isn't
gathered
it okay it doesn't need much it has
stretch without
it has give without extra skin right
oh those knees yeah
i guess so butt holes but
shout out to the hole shout out uh ep of
the podcast
buttholes um
or like have you ever seen a woman that
gave birth and her stomach
can be a little uh wrinkly mm-hmm darker
interesting i bet they love it but i bet
women love it when that happens to their
bodies um
well yeah my because i'm so pale
mine isn't that dark
right it's probably pink
you hate to have a tell but
well pink is a white person's dark you
know yes
but it's not yes not every white
person's i thought of another one thing
about your
nipples in fact i remember the first
time i took my shirt off in front of
dave
he remarked why your nipples pink oh no
i we were on the same page
so you're either you know dark
or slice of ham um he said it
like yo why your nipples like whenever
we were saying things
that were uncomfortable we would talk
like tron
the character or uh and then that became
rick james goodbye
why are nipples back um okay
you've got math i've heard the argument
too many times that an alcoholic can
give a drinking but no one can give up
eating
i think it's another excuse i know it's
hard to eat healthy maintain a healthy
weight 100
of the time but alcoholics still drink
i.e water soda
so it isn't a matter of not eating it's
about not eating junk food
candy pastries etc and liver veggies
fruit etc being overweight's hard
dieting and exercising is hard
choose your heart this is this is
uh the devil trying to tempt me back
into my old ways
don't do it and uh stay safe chris what
i'm telling you is
we can have empathy for
our brothers and sisters that are
afflicted with
uh uh will called
disordered eating and we just have to
sympathize and hope that they can come
through it
good listen to the star horrible podcast
but
wow that's nice what a what an existence
the bracelets are tight what in
existence gang goodbye hey
this is james aka hong kong jimmy hey
back in the day you would actually like
him
you would he seems cool yeah you would
but you would i could see you dating him
oh doesn't he have a girlfriend no
he did no he didn't he was in fact he's
written about
having hard times finding a gown in
hong kong um
back in the day i dated a scandinavian
girl out here we weren't compatible for
a bunch of reasons and it didn't work
but we
somewhat remained friends regardless uh
when we were dating she would always
playfully say how
much she wanted quote a chocolate baby
which i would always cringe at and wait
is james black
yeah all right and he
he he wouldn't he also wouldn't you
couldn't pay him to be a white person
so that's another thing so there we go
um
which i would always cringe at he's from
the bay and he moved to
hong kong seat kind of he just was sick
of american racism
and he was like i need repression i need
political repression
um uh well chaka baby
but he thought it was just the cultural
moors of europe not exactly being
politically correct on such matters
anyways fast forward to now i recently
discovered she's living in europe
and is now pregnant side note last year
she posted a photo on her instagram
story
that i uh had noticed i noticed had a
chocolate friend of mine in it
which i thought was a bit strange but
figured they were maybe just at the same
event
a [ __ ] event though he hasn't been to
hong kong
uh they definitely did not hang in the
same circles
so it was a moment of cognitive
dissonance back to the story when i
found out that her baby was indeed going
to be a chocolate baby
kind of had a crazy theory that it was
my friend who might
be the father but thought it was maybe
too much of a stretch and dismissed it
she's uh quite quite a pretty gal
he has support yeah spelled a g-y-a-l
uh guys the level of clever in these um
letters is touching um that's of course
caribbean woman gail
and he wouldn't be the only chocolate uh
she is quite a pretty gal
and he wouldn't be the only chocolate
man in continental europe to want to
impregnate her after all
what were the chances fast forward
recently i was texting with her and i
found out that he is in fact the father
which blew my mind i get the impression
that this was unplanned thing uh
resulting from a hookup
wrap it up fellas uh he has kind of
disappeared
in the last few months and doesn't know
that i know all this i also don't think
he knows that me and his baby mother
used to date
um this being a blessed time
to bring a baby into the world i don't
want to be a distraction but
should i casually tell him that uh he
wasn't that
that that she was an ex of mine or have
it come naturally
um later down the road uh
ps related i'd like to thank neil for
the term factory settings every time i
think i'm an amber with a girl i just
remember that they are most likely just
factory settings
and i shouldn't sweat it oh you knew you
messed him up
i no he's thanking me okay
um no you didn't read the good part
how nikhil feel and what binky
key thiefy is that the good part that
might not have been the good part
um uh i uh
no let her tell tell let her do it don't
tell him
say can you tell her to tell him just
say hey fyi
that i actually know him i don't like
i would just consult her she seems cool
my worry
not my worry i bet she knows he knows
him
is she homie hopper i think that's what
i'm trying to say
she's a homie hopper
international colon
chocolate chocolate the french spelling
the juliet
uh vanoce uh
so she's a chocolate homie hopper
yo colin she's an international
chocolate
it's ultimately what we're talking about
then you know
yeah not my problem
is this i'm not like i think you just
i think it's like how are they going to
hang out with his wife releasing the
names i think you just got
i don't it's one of those things like
okay i can't call it
and i there no one's asking me to call
it right
i think you just i don't know
i do i truly don't know what i would
because if you don't talk to him very
often
i don't know i mean but then there's
also the thing of like
letting him know she's a homie hopper
internet she's an international
chocolate homie hopper
but but does it matter he's not the name
of the [ __ ] [ __ ] of course
you're a [ __ ] sucker if you don't
think that's the name of the podcast um
do you know
okay okay so let's just let's do the
opposite he goes yo
friend i [ __ ] your baby mom
we dated she's my ex like there's no
that's not what's the there's not
there's nothing fruitful is gonna come
up
yeah what's funny is you we've all had
people we know
date people we know and they don't know
that we dated that person
yeah and then when how have you felt
before they found out
do you care well there's
two sides there's like the
the power element of like this
[ __ ] this coin [ __ ]
doesn't know i done
um hung dick up in there one of the
grossest
terms for the grossest
at the absolute grossest there's the
power thing and then there's also
the feeling like a type
well it wants to look like a guy but if
i see a guy well there's ch
international chocolate humming alberts
but then there's also just like chuckle
[ __ ]
you know there's so many chocolates and
then there's international chocolate
chocolate
so like do if i know someone's a chuckle
[ __ ]
that makes me feel less powerful
because i feel like i was just one of it
had nothing
so if that lasted i wouldn't it wasn't
really a
in fact i had a i have there's an a
different
chuckle [ __ ] which is
women that i've
dated slept with whatever who then on
who then went on to
be interested in comedy professionally
oh that's
weird that's like uh i've had a few of
those
and that's one of those things where
you're like uh
is it do you think it's like you
transferred the comedy spirit to them or
do you
think they was always in them and that's
why they were even attracted to you
that's where you can't look at it too
closely because meaning not like you're
afraid to look at it i don't know
i don't know what their motive was how
does it feel for you it feels a little
weird it feels i don't like it
no but it's like when girls go you're
just into asian girls yeah i like
[ __ ]
asian eyes no i like i like dark
asian eyes yeah i like dark haired like
a lot of asian
almost in fact not almost unless they
did something
asian women have dark hair so that's
in falls into the category but you've
dated of course
but that's when if you date an asian
girl they go
i because i said it on netflix oh yeah
the asian girls would be like oh you am
just another funny because your ex was
yes
asians didn't look it so yes
anyways you screwed do you now are you
like careful what you put
in specials so you don't get so it
doesn't
yeah yes okay just because it's not
worth it
is it worth the setup it's i could have
made that anything
other than asia black i do yeah that's
so funny and by the way if i'd said
black women
i would my black dm business would have
increased
seven thousand percent um
my my inventory okay so would you
would you let your friend know if you're
just like minimal friends you don't talk
often
i think you just let it slide don't
especially because if the baby came out
of a one-night stand
it's not like even but even if they're
getting married i don't [ __ ]
i don't know because i don't know the
nature of yeah their relationship
but it's not it's a good question i just
don't know
it's unanswerable so it's chinese it's a
it's an unanswerable chinese riddle
goodbye you've got
you're healing no or no neil
great lstner tuesday morning accolades
liar because it doesn't come out till
four pacific
um i met my last girlfriend at uh
college in arizona in 2005 and spent two
years as friends getting to know each
other well
and falling in love and started dating
in 2007. we were together for seven
years quite a bit of time
so uh we were apart doing long distance
while she went to school
in alabama before she moved to boston uh
to attend
and and graduate from burke berkeley
school of music
um we've been through a lot together but
i was the one who ended things because i
didn't think she would ever grow out of
certain selfish traits
and she was used to having everything
provided for her while
i had a job and had been paying all my
bills since i was 14.
uh we have since been apart for five
years
while she was she's been working for a
music publishing company in new york
we rarely contacted each other during
the time and i did my best not to reach
out and give her space
neither of us have had a serious
relationship since breaking up i
traveled for work and
was in her hometown last october for
work come to find out she moved back
today
long story short he's saying um
should i simp uh
they hung out she facetimes me every
night sometimes more than once a day
while i love reconnecting with her it
feels
i feel it's detrimental to me as i would
get back together with her
at a moment's notice oh should he read
into it
her interest and
is it like is she is she does she have
platonic intentions or is she just
lonely is she using him what's the
uh and can former love heirs get back
together um
uh i don't know i
i i'm not a fan of getting back together
i've never gotten back together with a
knife
i've done it but i'm not a fan really
whereas you've drawn the line
you won't even entertain it because i
feel like the type of relationship
dynamic
that just happens that i'm obviously
taking
uh part of but it i'm extremely
supportive
and they really have to accept the
support and the balance of power gets
tilted pretty heavily to them
so at the end of it they just feel
like like you work for them i work for
them i feel a little not
used but definitely taken for granted
on every relationship so no
it's whenever i think of an ex like
instead of should i get back in a
relationship for me it's do you want to
go back to prison
just voluntarily walk back in sit in
your old cell
i thought i was pessimistic
i just i no mon to the next goodbye uh i
don't think you can get back together
with exes
because you will revert
back to who you are in your core
within six weeks unless you've done
minimum eight ayahuasca journeys and
all of my advice i will i will entertain
it if they did iowa yeah yeah
and or i also don't think you should get
back together because
it's i always see it as like a reunion
tour
of like remember right i think a lot of
marriages are like that like remember
that year and a half where we were
[ __ ] bananas about each other
let's try to get that like let's we're
just constantly seeing if we can get
we'll get it back in windows or like
it's constantly about when i first met
your mother
right and when i met when this one first
came into my life and not enough about
the present tense
and too much about the past so it
becomes um
the punky brewster reboot
goodbye you've got mail hey neil and
binky day one
tuesday downloader wednesday on my way
to work lstner
no need to bore you with other details
love it
in listening to the podcast for so long
i noticed something neil casually
mentions wrestlers and wrestling
numerous times
just on this week's episode he called uh
pierce morgan a heel
as someone who hides his wrestling
fandom from most everyone uh
in my life i gotta know neil are you a
closeted wrestling fan
if so have you ever thought about going
to write for wrestling
for wwe who's your favorite wrestler
thanks for reading my email
and can't wait to hear back okay
i there's a few things here i don't
watch wrestling at all okay but it's a
wonderful metaphor it's just that for
fake activity yeah for fake storylines
faked activity fake
relationships fake conflict so that's
what wrestling's great for
if you want to know there someone wrote
an article
and will like put it in the notes
somewhere
in the like link i don't know i've never
clicked on the podcast i don't know
what's under it but um
someone wrote an article about donald
trump
and wrestling and uh the term kfabe
meaning it doesn't it just all it
requires
is emotion from the audience so you know
how trump would completely contradict
himself he can contradict himself
back to back right in uh speech
but if he gave the audience a line to
boo
it was great right like we got a free
mike flynn
but lock hillary up free mike flynn yeah
lock hillary up yeah and you're like
those are
totally contradictory like this guy
whatever we won't get anywhere it was
just
generating emotion without me there was
no context there was no
there's no future there's no past so
that's the beauty
that's one of the it's the best article
about trump i've ever read
um and it was uh it's actually not that
one whatever
um yeah um and it one of them mentioned
and amusing ourselves to death so you
know that i i had to doubly love it
writing for wrestling they have
comedy writers right for wrestling
sometimes not even sometimes like guys
this guy named tommy blanchard wrote for
conan and then went to write for
wrestling
it's the [ __ ] funniest and he had a
story that i think about every time i
got an airplane i get on it or i got
when i used to fly on airplanes
um the wrestlers have to fly
from [ __ ] wichita to oklahoma
just like puddle jumper flights right
but they're six
eight right yeah so
the story is a guy was there was a guy
sitting in uh in a just a regular person
sitting in the emergency exit row
and a wrestler walked up and was like
look at me look at you get up
which is so [ __ ] funny every time i
get on a plane i want to do that
like but like get up and i was like okay
just got up like it he
he commandeered my seat there's
something i can do um
so you don't have a favorite wrestler no
i don't even i wouldn't even know how to
like i don't know
no i like what do i name one besides i
can
ric flair nick flair of course um
uh the hulkster
[ __ ] the rock watcher man macho man
randy savage one of the greatest
of all time ted dibiase uh
randy rancho man savage is one of the
greatest wrestlers of all time and if
you don't
believe me look up macho man savage
cream of the crop
and it's a perfect comedy performance
when i tell you we'll just watch it
right now okay
wrestlemania three at the silver home in
pontiac michigan it's a day that i'm
certain my guest at this time will not
forget
i'm talking about the former
intercontinental champion of the world
macho man randy
nothing means nothing what do you mean
by that i'm talking about all the way to
the top yeah
unjustifiably in a position that i'd
rather not be in
but the cream will
right now card stacked against the macho
man randy savage in wrestlemania 3. hey
let me see it here
let me say it out loud and let me point
to the president of the world wrestling
federation the macho man randy savage is
not
happy with your decision yeah i am the
queen
in the world wrestling federation there
is no doubt about it yeah you
mean gene oakland you know that i'm the
cream of the croc
wait a minute though randy i've got to
ask you very seriously do you blame mr
jack honey
the distinguished president of the world
wrestling federation for ricky steamboat
being the intercontinental champion
today
yeah i do hear outside interference here
in my moment of glory yeah no i'm living
that nightmare
and i am the queen
and there is no one that does it better
than the macho man randy savage on
balance off balance doesn't matter
and i'm talking everyone in the world
wrestling federation and i'm even
talking
is gonna stop me nothing's gonna stop me
you know just out of curiosity randy
stop it it's he's because he's
writing it as yeah of course he's the
cream falls off his head he's
on balance off balance doesn't matter
and he's so you're he's writing it and
doing them
he knows he's pulling creams out he
knows he has to close with cream
right so he he's going i gotta close
by saying cream again but if i take the
third one out
i'm [ __ ] i have no closer so he does
one
two creams three realizes i can't
four realizes he can't then for five
he what it's unbelievable what does he
do
he he he saved the cream
for the last so he could close with
cream if
he got lucky it fell off but then he
rewr he does a rewrite on on balance off
balance
lands on uh gene oakland picks it up
so still has it it's [ __ ]
unbelievable and i think we can use it
because no one feels like you should
write
for wrestling i would love to
but i've got a podcast okay
goodbye you've got mayonnaise hey
needing bb i'm a late 20s working
creative person
with a bipolar depression who've
struggled my with substance abuse since
i was a teenager
i'm three days sober my 19 year old
sister looks up to me a lot and has
become
began cycling through smoking weed
regularly
excessively then quitting then starting
again
sure she's not exactly on the brink of
death but my story
started similarly over the past decade
i've alternated between two states
uh hyper productivity achievement
achieving goals and participating in
life
and then binges with various substances
isolation and depression
um each phase can last anywhere from
weeks to months and seemingly turn on a
dime when it comes to drugs i've told my
sister that
it's not about strength or weakness
weakness it's about dna
some people are built for moderation
others are not i'm not
i've been lucky so far you have to be
honest with yourself
um is this a journey she has to
experience for herself
should i be more aggressive in my
warning she also mentions my
conversation with carl hart
and she agrees that adults should be
free to choose but i can't help but feel
like i'm
watching my sister head towards a cliff
this is the oh this is my argument
against carl's point
what he's saying is
that the reason people get addicted
is because of an existing psychological
issue whether it's trauma
mental illness whatever and
but he's like but it should be legal
anyway and
my only worry is there's a lot of people
with trauma
especially in america yes now so then
the alter
the alternative is we keep it legal
i'm sorry we keep it illegal and punish
black people
because of the population's
use of not you so it's just uh
potential mental illness it's not again
i think you not have to let the chips
fall where they may but
in some ways you do because we can't
keep doing this
is there a way to just isn't there an
alternative to
like a real a real effort to
decriminalize it
of course yes of course but what i'm
saying is
her sister this person has is bipolar
so
and has abused drugs and they've had a
deleterious effect on her life so when
when we know that there are people with
diagnosed mental illness
right in the world how do we mitigate
uh the legality so that
so you're bipolar right and if it's
legal
but you probably shouldn't take it
mm-hmm
but it's also legal it's like okay
alcohol's legal you shouldn't have
epilepsy don't watch a stroke like i yes
of course
it's not it's it's i'm so in awe that he
took on such a topic
because it's so yeah it's so nuanced and
like
yeah it's really easy to drown in that
topic no matter what
side you take yeah so
he doesn't he didn't have canned answers
which was
noble on his part right but you need
some you need something in this kind of
thing because
someone can whether he realized or not
he was campaigning
he was campaigning for and while he
didn't want to go like
bianca i'll tell you why he didn't want
to be like a politician and hold a pen
bianca with my new plan um
so
yes i don't know what to tell people
who are
diagnosed with mental illness and
a lot of times their meditati their
medication is
these these
you know otherwise relatively harmless
drugs
right they're drugs plants again
don't forget who i am not for one second
if you forget who i am i will hiccup um
so i
yeah i don't know what to i think you
can tell your sister
but i also know enough about life that
it's people have to learn lessons on
their own yes it's impossible to learn a
lesson
in theory it well it depends i love a
good
other than you the hillary duff gay
thing you can learn that lesson
you learned that listen i learned it
before that but um
i love a good
learned lesson from your experience they
they work on me yes but
from other people from other people i
don't need ever
need to like so many things i remember
when i was young
the gay thing this story i'm about to
tell you it's all happening mostly in
like
middle school but uh i discovered
stealing
and i couldn't believe it was a thing
that you could actually do
and so me and everyone's like let's go
steal
and so we would have these we'd steal so
much [ __ ] from the mall
and then one day i didn't go with my
friend and she got
arrested and had to go and she was under
probation all that stuff whatever you're
underage
but it did not dawn on me that we could
get in trouble
it was just so easy and so when i
understood what happened to her
i never saw another day in my life but i
know there are some people who
really have to that's a cl that's
i don't think that first of all that
little girl
was me um um
that's what you call a year-long
callback um
that's a [ __ ] close call no that's a
close call and also close calls are
scary but
if someone says you know i did this one
thing and like
this hap sometimes things just aren't in
my brain and when it gets in my brain
the world expands and now that's part of
my fear
so i it really i like people's stories i
like people's horror stories
i i like it so it works for me but some
people
need to live the failure you know yeah
close calls are almost but they're i put
them in second
like learning at first hand okay close
call is a
close second okay close calls close but
i don't have told something
i love being told though i do i like it
yeah what about you do you need to
live it or can't you just hear like a
certain
workout from my friend
you like you like a you like when people
tell you i like wisdom
there's certain things that you can't
i'm thinking chris was saying some rock
was saying something
yesterday about uh jokes a
type of joke and i was like yeah but
when you say it
and it was about mean jokes right and
he's like
he basically saying like no you can get
away with it i'm like
when you say it it's joyously
mean when i say it it is mean
right it's like so there's like certain
advice is just not applicable
right and so it's knowing when
when it's applicable um but there are
some people especially with drugs and
alcohol who
i'm gonna take this journey i'm going
this way
to that point you're to that point i
don't know if it's it's not a close call
because i i wasn't going to be in len
bias's college dorm
um i wasn't supposed to be there that
night but
me and davey's talk about all the time
len bias died
wait who's that len bias was the number
three
he was the best player
in college basketball behind michael
jordan
gets drafted by the boston celtics
buy some coke with his friends that
night heart explodes
he dies oh my god it's crazy
they do 30 for 30. yeah i'm sure yeah
they've done
yeah and um like when you see him play
it
he kind of makes michael jordan wow
really
not like he can jump the same
[Music]
he's as athletic as michael jordan but
built
yokier right um
and that's one of those things where
that's i've done cocaine twice
i've really once once i've done cocaine
once
and i and it was i was 36 because i just
was like
i don't know they just worked on me
right like no that's what's going to
happen to me i'm going to do it once i
did it the night of my company central
space because i thought it would be
funny if i died
um that night at one line and uh
so that's that's the alternative
like i that's not a close that's just
hearing about something right
that's almost a scary time it's scary
that's what i'm saying like it did work
like i don't know i know so i don't know
anybody that's done
heroin yeah because or crack
because it was just the campaign worked
on the next generation you know
yeah craig is wack and then heroin
needles who's
doing that well now hopefully everybody
oh that's what this whole thing was a
circular way to this is one of the most
people
dr fauci thanks for calling in that's
all the time we have for today
guys thank you we don't have to take
this [ __ ] and we're not gonna take this
[ __ ]
and goodbye to you goodbye
[Music]
um
[Music]
um